celine dion's courage was out at
midnight tonight and she decided to
spend the moment at lips drag queen show
palace in New York City yeah it was
advertised as a celine karaoke party but
fans got a big surprise when celine
showed up and i got to give a shout out
to my friend mike taylor who was there
and sent me this video to show
[Music]
[Applause]
we know that well I heard you love drag
queens that way you look George I think
I believe this right now it is 12
o'clock which means one thing
[Applause]
I just I just can't believe it I am more
than so excited I'm so honored that
you're here tonight
[Applause]
[Applause]
this lava has been a long process it has
been making me travel through different
emotions but I just want you to know
that this is something like this I'm
working has been bringing me so much I
[Applause]
mean it I'm sorry now I took it in a
while it took a while it was a process
but thank you so very much for all your
support through the years and for being
here tonight
and I'm so glad that this album is out I
know
I hope Renee will like the Iowa
that's so beautiful miss lien wasn't
done there oh we should go next she
didn't leave the stage but she came back
to get in on the karaoke action see him
buy my own for my herb from Robin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I love first of all how cool is that
your friend was there just Denise is
saying what I was gonna go there next
week everything about when she starts
singing is that clear like the audio and
the production aren't so she's telling
guys like no no like turn my mic up turn
them up to them accompany me down then
she's like I'll whatever I give up just
I say how cool Kristin says she wasn't
lying with the album being a long
process a new song lying down I first
heard about it in 2017 new Ross is my
queen
Nicky says I'm not Canadian but she is
my queen that mrs. Bush I was there
Greta's nice representation for her to
go and notice that she's always been
amazing to her get followers incredible
she's the sweetest yeah and I'm so
excited about her album because I
actually got to see her perform what's
in New York know LA I went down for a
few hours and she did a performance them
with like a hundred of us to launch her
new album courage so it's great to see
that smiling